not all immigrants are created equal and
an immigration policy that does not
recognize this will end in disaster and
tragedy something that's going on across
Europe right now because obviously we've
seen these Hamas rallies and this Pro
Palestine stuff we've seen it in
Brussels and we've seen it in France and
London and elsewhere uh but but Ireland
has a really bizarre situation going on
where they're they're extremely Pro
Palestine it's it's asra maybe you can
explain a little bit of what's going on
on that but but not only that they've
also had a bunch of stabbings and all
other violent attacks by illegal
immigrants it's led to riots and a whole
bunch more uh but they do have
occasionally a senator that Wisin up to
some of this this is Irish Senator
Sharon kogan and listen to her make the
connection between illegal immigration
having no borders and the obvious
results of that firstly Ona H statement
yesterday that it is not right to
connect immigration with crime is
ridiculous not all immigrants are
created equal and an immigration policy
that does not recog recognize this will
end in disaster and tragedy we don't
record crime statistics by ethnicity
because to do so would offend liberal
sensibilities but other European
countries do the Dutch do they've done
it for 10 years and here's what they've
found individuals from non-western
immigration background make up 14% of
the population in the Netherlands
however they commit 40% of all crime and
violence assaults populations from
Africa or the middle East tend to
exhibit rates of two to four times
higher than those of native Dutch and in
both Germany and Spain the suspect rate
of Algerian immigrants for crimes is 10
times that of Natives and in Italy it is
17 times and Ireland has the largest
groups of Algerian Asylum seekers in the
world being admitted into the country
asking us not to asking us not to commit
connect crime to immigration is asking
us to ignore reality when now Ireland
has the eyes of the world World on it
and they're posed to see how this
country is being turned into a
post-democratic EU vassel state which is
about to pass censorship legislation the
likes of which we've never seen in the
west so that its government will be
protected from the criticism of the
people it is elected to
government maybe maybe that will pause
give them pause for thought but I won't
hold my
breath okay this Brave woman is
obviously telling the truth and I think
in most Western European capitals if
they could reverse everything they did
for the last 10 years they would Angela
Merkel has even admitted in Germany and
yet asra it's exactly what we're doing
right now in America letting all of
these people in and not all cultures are
equal are they yeah you know and I told
you guys the story of arriving in this
country in the 1960s and the Muslim
Brothers arriving as my father did well
my father refused that Saudi money right
in building a mosque in the United
States but what the fundamental problem
is that the immigrants that are coming
in from Muslim countries that want to
replicate the most totalitarian systems
that they knew of religious
interpretation or want to then also put
on the United States or the west and
Europe are the ones that are gaining so
much power this woke Army that I write
about is not just in the United States
it's in Europe it is the farle in Europe
that has aligned with the islamists that
have created these quote Pro Palestinian
rallies but they are not prop
Palestinian just like you said they are
at a minimum anti-israel and
anti-jew